you looking forward to the holidays I'm
a gravy guy what I'm a gravy guy that
was that so that's your like gravy Conan
okay that just sounds weird the way you
say now that grab you so much I don't
use the other appetizers and they're
just they're space fillers I like gravy
I'd like to get it all over me I like
gravy I'm a grave you guys do that gravy
stop saying it that way if we were on a
subway or a bus I would move way down if
you were next to me going I'm a crazy
guy I'll tell you what I married the
yoga Martha Stewart my wife woman over
do you know people who married above
their station yes I do
yeah I'm one of them I understand I've
met your wife lovely lovely beautiful
everyone who meets my wife says oh man
you lucked out you idiot you just
totally hit the jackpot I'm married
above my station and my wife who makes
the gravy from scratch doesn't like me
to microwave it because it destroys the
integrity of the gravy right but I don't
care right I'm a gravy guy and I like it
hot okay it's coming across John it's
coming across weird when you keep saying
it like that I'm just telling you as a
friend let me try this watch this hi I'm
a gravy guy thank you
how many days have you been without
gravy well I like to I like to save up
because we got the holidays coming I get
some great John I just turned into Chris
Rock
Chris I've seen Chris do an hour just on
gravy you do would you love to have your
own gravy boat I have to say I'm one of
those guys cuz I like gravy too when I'm
sitting ahaha but I don't goranson I'm a
baby yeah you're phony baloney you'd
like to you called me a phony baloney
we don't use that kind of language on
cable well we're gonna start okay the
big night I would like to have extra
gravy I would say I like to just really
drench my whole plate in gravy I think I
get a little nervous when I see other
people using it I feel bad because we
always host The Stray friends and people
out here who aren't going back to New
York or someplace for the holidays and
so we host the strays and I get my own
gravy boat you have your own yes selfish
self-absorbed I don't care I want my
gravy I can't believe we've been talking
about gravy for seven goddamn minutes
let's see if we can make it 14 what
about having a bucket around your neck
like a horse it's filled with gravy you
eat the other food dry and then in
between bites you close your face into
the bucket you take it on you're a guy
I'm so doing that it's not you're gonna
do that I'll be at the hardware store
tomorrow
you